this has been a complete shambles and
the fact that the chancellor has been
forced this morning through panic and
fear to issue a statement saying that he
would bring forward
the the event planned for October the
31st just shows how much chaos the
government has caused and we are now as
a country
paying a Tory party premium on
government borrowing and mortgage
holders are paying a Tory party premium
on their mortgages and the truth is that
the people who set fire to all this the
people who cause the chaos simply cannot
fix the damage that's been caused
should the Prime Minister stay in post I
don't see how she can possibly stay in
post the policies that were announced in
the original Mini Budget on September
the 23rd where the policies that she
fought and won the conservative
leadership election on so which policies
does she now believe in the ones that
quasi-core time announced which are now
having to be publicly torched by his
successor or the ones that are going to
be announced today and that's not just a
question for today that's a question for
any general election in the future which
policies would she support which
policies which she campaign on the ones
that she believes in are the ones that
have been forced on her by economic
Circumstance the position is impossible
for her
are you calling for it to go
well I think I don't see how she can
stay she has no that's not my question
Mr McFadden with all due respect are you
calling for it to go we think she should
go because she's got no credibility No
Authority she caused this damage she was
a hundred percent co-owner of that mini
budget with classic and therefore if she
stays in post why is she staying in post
it can't be for the interest of the
country this is just the conservative
party looking after itself today and
they cannot fix the damage that they've
caused we've got the ridiculous
spectacle of the new Chancellor going
around the TV studios all weekend saying
he's going to restore stability who
caused the instability who caused the
damage who caused the premium on uh
guilt yields that we've been talking
about who has caused mortgage rates to
go through the roof it's being caused by
the Prime Minister and the conservative
government
so you would accept then that it isn't
uh Jeremy Hunt's fault he has been
brought in to try to steady the ship and
we were hearing from our previous
commentator to all intents and purposes
he is the de facto prime minister now
would you agree with that
well he's been in cabinet for nine of
the last 12 years his policy when he
stood for the conservative party
leadership was to have an even bigger
unfunded tax cut than the one that Liz
trust favored he wanted cooperation tax
to come down to 15 so I'm afraid I don't
believe that the answer to the chaos
that's been caused by the conservative
government is yet another fourth
conservative Chancellor in four months
the chancellor I want to see is Rachel
Reeves the government I want to see is a
labor government because the Tory party
now cannot fix the chaos that they've
caused
that takes time as we know are you
calling for a are you calling for an
election tomorrow I mean what are you
actually saying there well we always
want an election because we're the
opposition uh but what we're seeing is
that
their damage has now been done uh the
conservative parties caused huge
economic uh chaos uh you know we had the
deputy former deputy governor of the
bank of England seeing the other day
that in recent times you would have
compared the UK economy to see the
United States or Germany internationally
people are now comparing it to Italy or
Greece this is what conservative
economic mismanagement has done this is
what ideology over economics has done
this is what the belief that evidence
doesn't matter all you need is faith has
done it's been very politically damaging
but it's also been very economically
damaging for the country and it's got to
come to an end
the latest polls suggesting that if
there was an election a snap election
tomorrow which of course you say that
you want uh the conservatives would lose
something like 200 seats there are uh
reports that I'm reading over the
weekend that you're training Shadow
cabinet ministers on how to be in
government how's that going
uh I've not had any of that but I was in
government when labor were in government
last time I was a minister for uh four
years it's really important that we
think not just about being in opposition
but about the approach that we would
take and that's part of our job as an
alternative government
so have you been um teaching the
youngsters how to do the job I thought I
still was a Youngster key I'm slightly
hurt by that but I know I've not been
teaching but I'm always available for
advice if anyone wants it
okay how do you see the next seven days
planning out it was one of your previous
Prime Ministers Harold Wilson I think
who said a week's a long time in
politics oh these days I know as it
feels like a long time in in politics
and the speed of this reflects the chaos
that has been caused will obviously get
a statement from the chancellor today
but it looks once again like we want of
the obr report that should go with that
there's another point about this but I
think the real reflection on recent days
will be where we began which is that the
prime minister's position is impossible
now because
the government's attempted rescue our
Act is based on publicly torching
everything that she fought and won her
leadership campaign on
politics is brutal though finally isn't
it and you all whatever side of the
house you sit on you all go into
politics to make a difference you all
want to be public servants to make a
difference to this country to make it a
better country to make the people who
live here safe and secure and prosperous
do you have a word as another politician
a politician okay on the other side of
the fence but still you know she she's
been a she's been in the um in the
cabinet for 12 years now more or less do
you have some sympathy for her
I've always got sympathy on a human
level for people because you're right it
is a it is a brutal uh business so I I
think that's right but my broader
reflection on how we've ended up here
okay is that we've got to bring this
period to an end where all you needed
was faith and evidence didn't matter
that ideology could just blast
everything out of the way that
institutions were just there to be
disparaged and taken down that's been
damaging for British politics I'm afraid
the Tory party's been at the heart of
that and it's no damaging for the UK
economy in damaging for mortgage holders
too so we've got to not just change some
policies but bring to an end that
approach to politics too
it's good to talk to you as always thank
you very much indeed for joining us